[Music]
hi everyone my name is Scott Feinberg
I'm a customer engineer with Google
before I joined Google about ten months
ago I worked at the New York Times on
the New York Times cooking app yeah so
today we're gonna be talking about a
product that's been around for a little
while now renamed as of this week to
cloud build so cloud build is Google's
think of it like a sort of pay-as-you-go
serverless platform for C ICD so if
you've used things like Jenkins drones
circle CI Travis CI blank name followed
by CI you kind of know how these sort of
things work Google's approach is a
little bit different you don't pay for
static hardware to hold your test
runners and all that stuff there's no
slaves you just upload it we run it for
you as a docker a container and then
spit out the results for you so it's an
integrated experience into the rest of
Google cloud and it works really well
and what we're gonna do today is we're
gonna walk through step by step I didn't
realize there were animations on that
pitch um step by step on sort of how to
take a nap and add cloud build to it and
and adding that CI CD functionality to
your app so cloud build is not an answer
to every problem when it comes to CIC be
if you're looking for something more
advanced with really you know expressive
ways of deploying you probably need
something more robust like spinnaker
which is an open source project that
Google and Netflix launched a few years
ago but cloud build solves a water
problems and you can extend it as far as
you want to because every build step is
just a docker container so we're gonna
switch over to the live screen Oh boom
fantastic so we're gonna take a nap so I
currently have an app running on GK this
is a sample app that pivotal has called
the pet clinic so if you happen to you
know have any pets this is what your
your that might use waiting for it to
load but essentially it's running on a
gke in um containers and we're gonna
walk through how to actually add cloud
build to it and make sure the Internet's
actually connected yeah cool so the
Astra slow fantastic but it is running
it's in container builder here's my
cluster we have a couple different
processes that we'll be deploying out to
so this is the web process if you've
used gke
before this should all look familiar how
you actually access it so there's a load
balancer as you can see um and we're
gonna pull you out to it so we're gonna
do this all in cloud shell um so cloud
shell is basically just a hosted
development environment that already has
all of your like permissions and stuff
baked into it two-factor authentication
how many people here have used cloud
bill before it's a few people who have
used cloud shell before yeah it's pretty
cool I like it and so we're gonna open
up and the Peck Clinic app so pretty
straightforward most of what we'll be
looking at will be in the CLI here
everyone can see in the back when I'm
typing pretty much cool so we're gonna
check out beginning of our projects
because I don't trust myself to actually
type out all the code you'll see that I
have branches for all the codes so as
much as this looks like live coding I've
written it before so here we have sort
of just a very basic Java app looks very
familiar
but this Justin Justin MPA app we don't
have a docker file I'm in it yet there's
no cloud build this would just run so
this is packaged with maven and so that
will actually run the tests build the
jar which will actually run in the
docker container so for our first step
we're gonna check out the docker file
that would that we'll use for this ok so
this year we have a two-step process
very simple
we're gonna run maven package so this
runs tests builds the jar and in the
second step we copy the jar we generated
in the first step and that's the only
thing running in that docker file so
this makes sure that that image is as
thin as possible so that we don't have
to actually deploy maven to prod and all
the other build aspects of the of the
pipeline so initially so you know that's
the docker okay now if I ran docker
build
I won't because it takes a little while
that would build and we would have a
docker container that we could run so
the first step to actually add cloud
build is to add a cloud build yeah Mille
so it's very straightforward refresh and
there it is so first step very simple
we're actually just doing that docker
build so initially we're just going to
build this to latest later on we'll talk
about the semantics of actually how to
build that but this first step will
generate a docker container out of our
app so just run just runs that docker
build and stores it in Google container
our registry so this is all there is if
I went and actually ran that right now
and this would go up to Google servers
and actually run this build so that's
that's sort of the simple part as you
can see here in the name this is
specifying what is actually running that
build so in our container registry we're
pulling down a docker container to
actually run that build step so there's
a docker container that runs docker to
actually run that build for us okay so
our next step here it's actually add the
kubernetes that lot should get built so
this has already been deployed to the
GAE cluster in this example we will just
go ahead and just refresh it
and so we have a web PMO that actually
is going to use that container so as you
can see down here this is a pretty very
basic web dot a yam oh we're referring
to an image that the cloud build would
actually use we're specifying
environmental variables so this
currently connects to cloud sequel and
other things that we're passing to be
environment the cloud sequel proxy to
actually talk to cloud sequel so it's
not out in the open and that's all very
simple setup for kubernetes and this is
the load balancer and we'll talk about
what this migration file is in a second
okay so in the next step
oftentimes when you build a build a new
package you might add new assets so
that's a static file best served from
from something like a GCS bucket so in
this example we can very simply just do
a gsutil copy so container builder has
been given the permissions so so we've
said container builder you're allowed to
talk to this particular bucket and
you're allowed to copy things into it so
that so we don't have to do any weird
stuff to actually download a service
account on to our box we don't to worry
about that it's all managed by Google by
just assigning a I am role and so in
this example we would have a our load
balancer when it was presented with you
know public um assets that it need to
request it would hit this bucket instead
of going directly to the app and that's
all that's required for that
so the next thing is that that you might
have in a CI pipeline is you might
actually need to migrate your database
so in this example with spring boot we
don't actually need to migrate a
database it's a static app but in our
yamo all we're doing is doing a echo
essentially so what what this would do
if you were using something like rails
this would be like a bundle execute DB
migrate or if you're using any other
sort of migration tool you could make
sure that your kubernetes cluster only
ran that once so some people like to run
the migrations on every container that's
coming up for like a web process that
can lead to issues where you have
contention so you have multiple
processes running your a container by
putting this into a kubernetes job we
make sure that this only runs once and
what that actually looks like in cloud
build is we delete the delete the job
itself to make sure that you know once
it ran once and was successful we have
to delete it so we can run it a second
time and then in the second example here
all we're doing is running apply and
creating that new job and making sure
that it runs now a lot of our apps you
know you might have to wait to actually
deploy and update your cluster until
your migrations are done in a
traditional setup like this you'd say
okay well I'm gonna execute that how do
I actually wait for that and that's
where the beauty of cloud build comes in
where you might say okay well now I
can't you know just have a very simple
straightforward file luckily for us you
can extend cloud build to do whatever
you want and we have a bunch of sort of
pre-built docker containers that do
actions for you so we're going to talk
about one that I wrote called cube CTL
wait for and I thought I had it open but
there we go
so cute CTL wait for job
does exactly what it sounds like it
waits for a job to complete before it
lets you continue on so this is
literally a bash script that is wrapped
in a docker file that runs that that is
passed in the argument of your job name
so this basically tells cloud build hey
I'm gonna run this job but I want to
wait to actually you know do anything
else until this job is complete so just
a bunch of bash foo that is essentially
wrapping cube CTL get jobs and it's just
polling for that to actually be done and
cloud build handles all of this for you
once this is created in your projects
you can just pull that down and we'll
show how that works so locally I have
checked out the cloud builder Community
Edition so for things that are pre-built
it's reconnect first for things that are
pre-built like docker cube CTL you can
just reference that so those are just
complete and done you don't to worry for
things that are in the community or
things you write yourself you actually
need to have a copy of that running that
you can access in your registry so we're
gonna CD into that so cloud bill there's
community helps to not put a ' first so
we're gonna CD into cube CTL wait for so
as you see here we have that bash script
we have a docker file and we have a
cloud build file so what we're gonna do
and a copy from module
which I also thought ahead of so you
actually go ahead and submit to cloud
build to actually build our containers
so we have a little bit of inception
going on so what we're doing here is
we're saying X out of that G cloud send
up this cloud build and run it for me
and store it in my registry so this is a
cloud build that's just you just go and
grab and that's automatically going to
grab your current projects and your
current setup so this is actually
executing this is going to load up a
tarball and load that up to Google cloud
and run that on a fresh VM so loads it
up we can view the output so you can see
exactly what's going on ran through the
docker container the docker file and now
it's done so now if we go over to our
registry well actually see it cube CTL
wait for and here's the latest that was
just uploaded so now this is available
in my environment that I that I can
actually pull down head back over so and
so now that that's there we can go ahead
and head back into our pet clinic once
it lets me type again
you can let me connect
apologies network connectivity we are
reconnecting them but so now that we've
uploaded that we actually just need to
add to our cloud build to actually pull
that down and wait for that job is the
next step
waiting for this to load
that's not fun get that another second
okay let's make sure we're using the
hardwired apologies I know you've all
been enjoying the Wi-Fi this week so
we're gonna set up a hotspot as a backup
I did test this earlier so we do have a
backup solution cool it's going to take
a sec
did everyone have fun at the party last
night so I'd never heard of the
chainsmokers before I had to ask my
girlfriend I was like so who are the
chainsmokers
and then she was like oh they like play
the song you like and I'm like cool and
then I showed up and I was like they
don't sing that song so that was fun I
also didn't know who DJ spinderella was
so I apparently live under a rock okay
let's try another tap because that
sometimes works okay cool
look my Wi-Fi hotspot came in handy
fantastic so now we're going to head
back into our app and we're gonna check
out the next step so remember what step
are on now and this will update there we
go cube CTL wait for so what this is
waiting for is for the prior job to
complete so you see in cloud build we
have these IDs so every step optionally
can have an ID associated with it so by
default cloud build will just run your
jobs and from top to bottom unless you
specify that it can do things parallel
which you should have it do so that
things happen faster and in those cases
you might still have cases where you
want to say hey I want this step to
happen before this step but I don't
really care where in the whole file this
should actually run so you can put
together sorta as complicated as you
want before this after this statements
and that's what use these IDs for so
like in this case if I wanted to for the
assets I could say wait my public assets
only get generated
when Navin package gets run so I want to
make sure that I had the the latest ones
available so I could do wait for build
image and then instead of running those
parallely if I have that enabled I can
instead make sure that the latest assets
are actually up to date and that's very
important in this example when you have
something that's supposed to wait for
something you actually need to have that
that step to actually happen so you
might have noticed that cool so I have
this wait for but now I still haven't
done anything
I still haven't actually deployed so
I've run my I built an image
I've migrated my database I ran my tests
that happens in package so that'll fail
with my tests you know don't work but we
still have to we still actually have to
go and update our initial manifest with
our latest image so in our next step
will actually just patch our manifest
stash our changes
and here we go so in this so you know
very simply in use cases where you can
just update the image in less and let
kubernetes handle taking the containers
pulling them out and actually updating
them this works really well so we know
our databases in a good state now now we
need all of our containers to have the
latest code so we go ahead and we patch
that manifests that's running and then
and right now we're still just going to
update that image to just be the latest
version of pet clinic that we generated
in our first step so you know this is
all well and good but at the end of the
day you don't you probably don't want to
have to run you know container build
submit every time you run a see ICD
pipeline that kind of defeats the
purpose right so I'm gonna kick this off
and I'll show you guys how to actually
run this every time your code it's
actually executed so we had this thing
called build triggers so this is where
sort of the history so you can see that
I just kicked that off and you can see
that that's actually running in Miam
interface now so here each of the steps
that we have so far and you actually can
just get the latest log so in addition
to being available in the interface you
can also tale that from the build
details itself and if you wanted to
download the log load them into bigquery
or something and you can do that from
here as well you can see the images that
are actually generated so build triggers
so a build trigger is exactly what it
sounds like it's a trigger for running
your cloud build so I have two examples
here one is hooked up to github so if
you push your code up to github this
will automatically grab that
and run it so well so we'll show what a
what a build trigger actually looks like
so you can trigger it branch tag
whatever you want you can give us some
regex you can say only for something
like a Java app maybe you only want
cloudbuilt to run when one of your
source files changes not when you edit
your readme so that can be pretty
helpful if you know you care about not
doing excessive deployment when you're
just doing cosmetic changes and you can
substitute variables so as you saw back
here we have all these things that are
just dying you know as like a good coder
it's like wait you're specifying things
what if I want to change that later
that doesn't seem like the best place
for that so you can actually specify
things like your cluster your zone other
variables from your build trigger itself
so you could have a trigger for
deploying to dev staging prod and put in
your substitutes as required all it is
is a matter of just quitting add item
and specifying the variable so go ahead
and let this run and then we'll show how
that works and so you you can do this on
github you can hook it up to bitbucket
in addition to source repositories you
so those are the the three options you
have to actually trigger these of course
you could also sort of build your own
trigger by basically just taking your
code and pushing it I - - cloud source
through some other means and if you
wanted to just manually trigger these
you can just quick run trigger and here
we are back so running this so the other
thing to look at here is we are
currently running this and we're always
building to latest so that's that's
that's not really a best practice this
this would mean that every time you ran
a build you'd be telling your kubernetes
instances to just run that one and that
works great in dev it doesn't work that
well in prod when you want to actually
test your code prior to having it be
deployed so in a second we'll actually
show how that gets updated I'm still in
the build I'll just open up the next tab
there we go
this is actually running through all the
tests so takes a second that tab never
came back unfortunately
there we go okay so in our next step
will actually make that update so that
those substitute variables can actually
be used so update in a second okay so
we're doing a couple of things
differently here one is available to
your cloud trigger is the short straw of
the github of the git commit that is
being built so a lot of times you want
to be able to specify hey this build is
attached to this commit that I made so
this is a useful way of actually
checking that out in addition and you
probably want to have some sort of
semantics to say what that build is
initially being used for so in this case
we're gonna use something called a
deploy tag so this would be something
like dev or prod or staging so that you
know okay
this was built tagged with this new
update and this is what we're actually
gonna deploy that to so if you need to
do a rollback understand the the history
of that build so we have these changes
some of the semantics here are a little
bit different so this is if it's a just
a dollar sign that means it's provided
directly by cloud build if it's a dollar
sign followed by an underscore that
means you substitute it yourself so
essentially it's a poor man's name
spacing between what Google gives you
when when when you're building it versus
something that you define and you can
see that down here as well so now in our
trigger we'll have something called
compute zone and cluster that's
specified by us as far as where we
actually wanted to apply that to so as
long as you have given cloud build the
permission to the project where that
cluster is running this will all work
you can see that all the way down
and then here instead of setting the
image to latest we set it to the deploy
tag that's actually being run so let's
head back to our build see if we
finished we failed well we will rerun
that oh that's a different one here this
one succeeded so we'll actually go ahead
and just run our next step that actually
includes that so now that we have these
these changes initiated we can actually
in addition to running them through
cloud build you can actually test it
locally as well so I'm going to grab the
grab the substitution there I might
actually not have the substitution there
so it's basically the same as that
submit and then we can actually specify
substitutions so put that so yeah so
it's this submit substitutions equals
and then you actually can specify what
you want to change so in our case we
have a couple things so we have a deploy
tag so we can say deploy tag sequel dev
oh thank you
spelling is hard it's too early in the
morning I'm still in East Coast time so
we have computes own so we ran our Zone
in US central see it's gonna yell at me
for the under scroll
and in the actual build trigger you can
actually run these yourself but it's
pretty useful to be able to run this
local way several times without having
to push it up also just being able to
run your build without having to go back
to the interface committing nonsense
things like that so it gives you the
opportunity to really play with the the
build file and also when you know github
goes down you can still run it and what
else we got was the other one cluster
Thank You Syd if you guys write this um
cluster
I think it's Scott's pet clinic with an
extra - I spell my name with two t's so
I go ahead and run this and see if it
lets me
and so this is going to do that same
thing thar up the file upload it and
actually run it so cloud build at the
end of the day o invalid name great oh
yeah so this short shot is not available
locally so that's why that um error
happened so I can actually so while it's
not available locally I can actually
still substitute it so I can still go
short sha equals whatever one two three
and that'll get around that or I could
actually like look at what my short size
should be the other option
so this uploads it um Google is actually
going to run it on a fresh PM and Derek
Excel so that in a nutshell is cloud
built so it's it's you know very simple
it's very straightforward it's excellent
for these sorts of use cases where you
have a small app that you're not worried
about you know deploying you know doing
like a Bluegreen you're able to trust
who raised to deploy it for you and
hopefully you have some sort of test
suite that is gonna let you actually
accomplish CI CD other great benefits of
cloud build for doing these sorts of
things especially for small apps is that
if you don't have an existing C ICD set
up or perhaps you don't want to you know
spin up a new slave for Jenkins for a
new app cloud builders pay-as-you-go and
not just in the same sense as
traditional resources you paid by the
second that your build actually runs so
I think every day you got about a
hundred minutes for free of cloud build
and then you pay some number of pennies
after that but it's fully managed you're
not you don't have static hardware and
most importantly you're not
troubleshooting
your CI CD test runners and slaves when
when they happen to go down so you don't
have to actually like maintain this all
you're maintaining is a y mo file
in in your repo and that's cloud build
if anyone has any questions on cloud
build or anything like that we have mics
set up if anyone has anything
yeah so what what you what you're seeing
me do here this g-cloud is just a
wrapper for a API call so it's all
available as long as you have a service
account that can hit it you can kick it
off thank you no problem
is there anything built-in for
notifications like you know updating
status in github or something like that
when a build succeeds or fails or it's
not built in and but there are a couple
community projects that essentially do
that and so you can basically add a tag
in the same way can you trigger the
build from a local repo so yeah so
that's what so you can kick it off from
a local get a repo it's actually what
I'm doing here and you can't run a cloud
builder locally in that sense in sense
of like cloud build itself is not
executing locally it's just easier to
just load it out I mean pushing to a bit
bucket repo from Atlassian and then the
trigger triggers to build on cloud
builder yeah
so that's built-in so also you actually
just have to just link it and then every
time you commit to bit a bucket it'll
kick off the build I Scott great talk
can you talk about secret management and
if I'm injecting secrets into the flow
would it actually come up through the
logs or there's any like yeah so I if
you have actual secrets that you want to
deploy those should be living within
your kubernetes secrets file so I can
actually show you how that works I have
secrets in here that are protecting the
cloud sequel credentials so if you look
at the configuration here it's it loads
for a sec so I have these these secrets
they're not a they don't show you like I
couldn't make this show if I wanted to I
would have to download it on base64
encode it and to actually view what
these things are but substitutions
itself do eventually show up in the logs
so to actually use secrets you actually
want to have that run on kubernetes and
I'm executing it there that's one of the
reasons that like running your
migrations you should actually do that
on the kubernetes cluster not on cloud
build because you don't want to give
cloud build your secrets and it gives
you one place actually I managed us I am
aggression for model built systems are
there any tools that link to make any
tools that does that I to migrate from
which system for others a system for
instance Jenkins whatever there's not a
tool that would essentially like do it
for you like rewrite your pipeline but
it's a it's it's something that you know
if in Jenkins you're just running a
bunch of bash scripts you can execute
each of those bash steps within build
and assume you could actually take the
whole bash script throw it in a docker
container and execute it on cloud build
if you wanted to but ya understand that
I'm sinking modesty now just like I'm in
company and I have 203 posts it's going
to be quite an effort to migrate each
and one of them yeah but another
question and is there a way I if I
understand correctly you need to put
configure the pipeline I used just a
moment you need to put configure the
pipeline to to actually does dust now
let's say the user wants to change the
pipeline as part of the pl itself is it
possible I change what on the server the
pipeline let's say I'm let's say you
have a champions final sunset but and
you actually go and you know as part of
changing you change you want to change
the CI pipe writing itself and you want
to test it as part of the pl itself
let's say for get up yeah is it possible
to do the same thing with cloud below
yeah so cloud build so the yamo file is
just a part of your git repo so if you
wanted to experiment with it prior to
deploying you can do that locally but
then if you wanted to actually you know
you could just commit had the cloud
trigger do it as well okay thank you
yeah
it's got great chalk great demo had a
question just quick real quick ones is
that example repository gonna be online
or public exposed and also the cube CTL
wait for job
just keep CTO wait for job is public so
if you just go to cloud builders -
community it is right in there so so
this is sort of the UM think of it like
the blast community repo with a bunch of
stuff so you've helm in here firebase a
bunch of really good stuff and my sample
code will be available I'm not positive
which github account currently it's on
mine okay thank you problem hi thanks
for the demo sorry few questions the
first one the in the UI you were
triggering some you're configuring the
triggers is also available in the mo
file so you can do that all
declaratively in a file there's not yet
um I believe someone is hopefully
working on that but yeah that would be a
really nice feature and then for the
actual jobs are there any guarantees on
performance can we expect a similar
performance every time we run the jobs
for measurements yes so you can expect
that the job will execute the same
because it's a fresh VM of the same size
you can also specify different size VMs
so let's say that you have something
really really beefy and you want to run
like you know a bunch of parallel
threads in it you can do that and you
can use as big as an instance as you
want you can just specify that in the
cloud build thanks and sorry one last
question is there a way if you have a
lot of jobs coming in from a lot of
commits at the same time is there a way
to queue up and say there's only one
kind of deploy job happening at once or
maybe there's only one kind of
integration happening to like block the
deployment from happening during an
integration test yeah so there's no so
you could run an integration test in the
same cloud build prior to actually
deploying so that's what that sort of
wait for example works well as far as
like a cross cloud build orchestration
that doesn't exist as far as I know okay
thank you
hi there did a quick search and it looks
like it's only for kubernetes as there
plans to bring this to like functions or
app engine all right so you can use
cloud bill for anything yeah so it's
like just think of it like docker
containers in the cloud so you can so if
so you could run g-cloud app deploy for
App Engine the whatever the command is
for functions so you can use it for
anything it's really for those cases
where like with functions where you're
like great so I wrote this little
function I really don't want to have to
set up a whole like Jenkins setup just
to deploy this these six lines of code I
can just put a cloud build file and
it'll take two seconds and we'll just be
like essentially just like the deploy
step and that's it sweet thank you yeah
there from any other questions awesome
thanks everybody
[Music]